the next billion dollar startups list is
a list that forbes does in conjunction
with trubridge
and we look for companies that are on
their way to becoming
billion dollar valuation companies so
these are typically fast growing
companies but they're also companies
that have not just fast-growing
valuations but also often fast growing
revenue this year the average revenue of
the companies on the list was about 24
million that's about double what it was
last year
and so this year we're getting companies
that are
you know they're a little bit further
along in their
operations they're a little bit more
solid they have a little more revenue
where last year the valuations were
higher and so the companies were much
earlier stage we have
many tech companies on the list it's a
very tech focused list we do have
companies in cyber security
and in using software for trucking those
are areas that we've had before this
year we also have a couple of new areas
that we have not seen for example we
have a semiconductor startup which is
the first time that that's happened we
also have a weed startup which is the
first time that we've had anybody in
that space on the list
those companies are sterile labs and
semiconductors and leafling leaflink is
a new york city based
wholesale e-commerce platform for the
cannabis industry so if you run a
dispensary um you know you're gonna have
to stock your shelves with cannabis
products and basically leaflink is a
platform that you can use to buy
products from
thousands of different brands they've
been around since 2016. they've raised
131 million dollars from
vcs like founders fund and l2 and sarah
capital they
now currently have you know over 3 000
brands and over 8 000 retail shops
across 30 states using their platform
let me highlight also landing which it's
a company founded by a guy named bill
smith who's a alabama high school
dropout and serial entrepreneur who sold
his last company shipped to target for
550 million dollars and landing is a
company that does flexible lease
furnished apartments and so it's really
hitting that idea of we're going to live
differently we're going to be able to
work from anywhere and people want more
flexibility in how and where they live
it was a really big deal in 2015 when we
started the list to get to a billion
dollar evaluation it isn't any more in
companies they're hitting it much faster
but by doing the list we do still get a
very early look at some of the companies
that are going to be giant over time
you